Expresa 25 grados Celsius como una temperatura
en grados Fahrenheit usando la fórmula,
grados Fahrenheit o "F" es igual a 9/5 por
grados Celsius más 32.
Nos están dando una temperatura de 25 grados
Celsius, que podemos sustituir en la "C" aquí,
para obtener el valor correspondiente de
temperatura en grados Fahrenheit.
Hagamos eso, tenemos que "F" es igual a 9/5,
en vez de "C" vamos sustituir el valor de 25,
por 25 y eso más 32.
Podemos simplificar esto antes de que multipliquemos
9/5 por 25,
recuerda que esto es lo mismo que 9/5 por 25 entre 1.
Y ahora podemos, antes de hacer el producto,
dividir numerador y denominador entre 5.
Así es que, en el numerador 25 entre 5 es
igual a 5 y en el numerador,
5 entre 1 es igual a 1, esto nos queda 9 por 5 más 32,
así es que los grados Fahrenheit,
son igual a 9 por 5 = 45, más 32 ó
"F" es igual a 45 más 32, 77 grados.
Así es que esto es, 77 grados Fahrenheit.